monday edition of pftot
where we take some extra time to talk
about things we didn't get to on a busy
monday morning coming out of week four
chris sims mike florio here with you and
chris we didn't talk about washington
specifically as it relates to
the debut of dwayne haskins whose entry
into the game against the giants was
influenced in part by the foot injury to
case keenum it didn't go well three
interceptions in 17 attempts for dwayne
haskins and now jay gruden on death
watch in washington and i know you're a
believer that it's not his fault yes i
am right but sometimes that's the only
thing you can do right yeah i mean i get
it i i mean
i understand i guess i would say this
or this is what i would argue you know i
certainly don't think the redskins are
who they are because of jay gruden i
think there's a lot of issues with the
football team in general i think good
agree uh i understand that yeah right
now the perception is reality it doesn't
look good and sometimes you need to make
that change only thing i would argue
maybe to keep jay gruden right and the
biggest thing would be
i still think that a guy like dwayne
haskins is going to develop the best
under a jay gruden for the rest of the
year instead of shaking up the building
and then oh i don't know who's going to
be the head coach and who's going to be
the offensive coordinator so that would
be the argument i would make to the
redskins you know maybe you want to fire
him right now but i would go ooh i still
think jay gruden gives your new rookie
toy quarterback dwayne haskins the best
chance to develop as this year goes
along and then maybe you can make the
move after the year if that's what you
want to do but that would be my biggest
argument for him right now and here's
the thing yeah ask yourself yeah
what's it going to do to help you yeah
is it going to make you into a playoff
exactly exactly he's flipping from jay
gruden to bill callahan suddenly going
to start generating win after win after
winning right of course not and and you
know the bad part about that and
typically we'll see an interim coach
take over far later in the season you
get a couple of late wins and then you
get some momentum for
the interim coach to get the job and
then the interim coach gets the job and
the interim coach stinks once he gets
the job we see that far more often than
not so i i don't know what they should
do i think they have far more problems
than changing head coaches every four
weeks would fix but there was a report
from the washington post and i've heard
the same thing yeah danger for great j
gruden and it's something that we're
going to be keeping an eye on throughout
the course of the day they've got the
patriots coming to town next weekend
they don't have a bye week until week
10. they've got a mini buy after the
week eight game at minnesota those are
typically the more natural points on the
calendar yeah to make a change so your
interim coach has more time to get his
sea legs before he has to go coach the
game yeah no definitely i mean that i
mean that makes sense as far as when you
make the change the one thing i'll say
about this that i i don't understand
you know
if case keenum they knew going into the
game might be on a short leash right
yesterday and i think you heard me say
this in the in the room yesterday with
everybody
i don't know why if you felt like he's
on a short leash and he has a banged up
foot
they should have just gone with dwayne
haskins to start the week because they
put dwayne haskins in a tough spot
yesterday you know oh there he is he
gets to get thrown out on the road in
new york but didn't really get the full
week of practice and reps with the first
team to really put himself in a position
nor did the team get the game plan
specifically around him to go oh these
are the strengths and weaknesses of
dwayne haskins let's put a game plan
together that you know accentuates the
strengths and we can kind of hide some
of the flaws that would be my one
argument if you're just i just don't
understand that yesterday that's not an
argument but i just don't get that i
think if they got to tuesday or
wednesday they're like ooh case
kingdom's banged up and
i think we're gonna we're getting close
to the dwayne haskins times anyways they
should have just gone ahead and did it
and tried to formulate the proper game
plan around him instead of putting them
out there yesterday kind of like in a
bad situation there's been a suggestion
the coaching staff wasn't really on
board with drafting dwayne yes right we
haven't seen or heard much the first
month of the season to make us think
that's wrong yeah because it there's
just a weird dynamic yeah it does seem
like that there's no doubt and i mean i
also understand wayne haskins is raw i i
get that and he showed us that in the
preseason he's he's certainly not ready
for prime time yet uh but either way he
is the future and and uh i think they
need to start getting him going because
the season looks lost
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports